on ce dernier sprint de campagne tous
les efforts sont bienvenus les bénévoles
s'activent pour convaincre les indécis
comme cet homme qui ira voter mais sans
grand enthousiasme que par le système
voit
des gens qui travaillent qui ont des
fois debout aujourd'hui et qui arrive
quand ils font des enfants
ces militants du parti de gauche
radicale france est soumise de jean luc
mélenchon l'admettre il rencontre cette
année de nombreux français qui n'ont
même pas l'intention de participer à
l'élection les gens disent que ils sont
pas intéressés par la politique parce
qu'ils disent que ça ne sert à rien
d'aller voter et moi j'aurais explique
sentiment que oui non qu'on peut avoir
des avancées sociales et que oui la
politique c'est aussi quelque chose qui
doit leur intéressé il ya cinq ans un
grand nombre de français se sont
abstenus lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ici à metz
dans l'est de la france le tiers des
électeurs ne se sont pas présentés aux
urnes si on se fie au sondage
l'abstention pourrait être encore plus
importante cette année cette campagne
qui a été victime d'une actualité de
plus en plus vertigineuse vient se
surajouter à la crise sanitaire d'une
part et puis la crise citoyenne d'autres
pas sans surprise on va assister à des
élections un peu par défaut vous aviez
bouvet conseiller municipal à metz est
témoin du désenchantement d'une partie
de l'électorat selon lui il n'y a pas
que le peu d'intérêt suscité par la
campagne qui explique le phénomène c'est
une fatigue démocratique qui a des
racines qui sont profondes qui nourrit à
la fois par une forme d'incompréhension
du système politique des temps de
décision des complexités administratives
tout ça pendant des années a convergé
pour produire de l'éloignement
manque d'intérêt ou de motivation le
phénomène touche particulièrement les
jeunes électeurs selon des sondages
jusqu'à 40% d'entre eux pourraient
bouder les bureaux de scrutin dimanche
moi je sais que je veux pas il y en a
sûrement qui font pareil que moi et du
coup ça fausse les résultats on va dire
pour ce militant de greenpeace le manque
d'attention portée par les candidats
certains thèmes comme le climat n'a pas
aidé l'écologie toujours reléguées au
second plan pourtant c'est un sujet qui
peut être mobilisateur aussi notamment
des au niveau des jeunes sur ce campus
certains évoquent aussi un système et
des enjeux pas toujours simple à saisir
c'est compliqué de comprendre tout ce
qui se dit entre tous les candidats mais
qu'at elle à utilisera donc cette
application qui l'aidera à mieux
connaître les candidats et leurs
programmes et ainsi faire son choix tous
les moyens sont bons pour convaincre les
électeurs réticents ou hésitants c'est
très problématique pour la démocratie on
nous offre droit de vote c'est notre
seule arme et ces personnes l'utilisent
tondra encore et
candidates invisible à la présidentielle
l'abstention pourrait grandement
influencé les résultats de l'élection si
raphaël bouvier auclair radio-canada à
metz